well welcome welcome to your mom's house
with Tom Segura Christina the ship's
to your house my father texted me yeah
gotta tell you this a few days ago and
he text me that I put it on I put it on
Instagram he goes I'm in the Orlando
Airport
yo and I'm shitting in the stone ah that
I shat in 18 years ago Wow
so I wanted to see if I am on the phone
geez let's see the only into airport
Babli his chin is on the the outlet like
the cord oh hey Dad hey buddy hey dark
good man how's it going not good just go
get chillin right now yeah um happy
Father's Day of course again I'll be a
good one are you um yeah I did yeah I
wanted to ask you you texted me the
other day that you went to the Orlando
Airport and oh yeah yeah you ended up
kind of enough and ended up in the same
stall where I did my my famous shit of
19 years ago this was the shit that went
through your pants yeah yeah this is the
one where I had to leave my underwear in
the in the place and kind of just do the
best I could with my trousers and then
to get on the plane you know with a
brown spot and cracker you know yeah
oh this is the exact stall so it was
kind of yeah it ended up being kind of a
nostalgic moment you know what I mean
yeah you know you get emotional you know
well you know I didn't get emotional but
you know I I rise this is one of the
challenges that you face a life and you
have to you know I mean
I actually thought about having to go
home but I gutted it out and made my
flight and you know got into the new
place right so where were you flying to
do you remember oh I was flying key
I think I was flying to Arizona
so all logs like oh wow so you cross
country with Dookie on your pants got a
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah um wow
that's pretty that's pretty neat it'd be
kind of cool if you also were to go to
the same gas station in Miami that you
pulled over for your biggest should ever
remember that one you know if that place
still existed today it would be a
miracle I know really you know that oh
that we're talking by Miami standard you
know it's a kind of place where you know
and on the side you had transmissions
just discarded on the side oh wow
do you remember yeah did you finish that
shit did you tell mom about it at all or
no cuz it was so epic probably probably
yeah do you think she probably enjoyed
that or no definitely not yeah testing
that um you know also in that we've been
getting a lot a lot of people emailing
us about double pipe classics you know
oh yeah yeah and it's a rare event yeah
a rare event you know I can tell you
they're very rare
yeah when I had my last one that's you
know you can go a whole year to without
even yet woman yeah I mean Christina had
like her first one this year I think
first one in ages yeah you know and I
haven't had one this year um I haven't
had one issue either
yeah that's the thing is and people are
keep trying to they keep trying to
manufacture them and I try to encourage
them one out you can't you can't get
yeah yeah this one little thing yeah
you know some of those things that you
just you gotta let it happen alright
like you can't make it rain
you know this certain thing right right
yeah yeah exactly yeah
can you remember the last time yes make
it rain that's true yeah I mean because
then people will be like hey um I
sneezed and farted at the same time does
that count and I'm like no of course not
no sketchy dude oh that's exactly you
know it's not special looking you know
and they're not when you fart and or to
the same time and all that now and then
you know and it sounds different too
because you have you know yeah yeah I
mean you got a thing about music the
reason it's so rare to is that you got
air coming out of both ends you know
usually you can it picks a it picks a
road you know it doesn't actually go
down both oh yeah it you know it's right
you actually getting punching the dead
it goes both ways yeah
yeah it's really it's really something
so I remember the last time I had one of
those you know I haven't had one that I
would really remember it I'm pretty good
about my classic moments but can't take
it this one Wow see that just shows you
that you as the master haven't even you
don't even recall your lap I remember
having one I believe and we could
probably find it in our show a year ago
and it's you know for me probably maybe
the third or fourth ever very rare
they're so rare and every time though
it's a really special moment a lot of
people have let us know about their
first time and they're like it happened
to me today is really spectacular
well yes yo you bury just say you know
there's only one first time - first
times right right right
that's true so have your you know I'm
going to go see a specialist actually
because I have so many catastrophic
shits that I'm actually going to go
check my guts out really yeah I mean I
don't know that I have anything medical
for sure
but I just figured you know I could just
check it out see if
maybe not OSI food allergy and I could
if I could do my career all over again
I'd really want to be a
gastroenterologist oh yeah you're made
for it but just it fascinates me what
goes on inside there and guts yeah well
you know I took a man I got bronchitis
I took an antibiotic as an antibiotic
I've never taken before well I had the
hardest shits out there and you're like
really
I'm a were talking we're talking onesies
and twosies okay how long ago was this
but it's just two weeks ago
oh really Clinton I remember was it last
year when you had the real hardships and
we talked about hydrating ELISA
yeah but this was really dude an
antibiotic so I loaded up on Metamucil
the six or so didn't make a difference
once I quit once I quit the antibiotic I
knew I was out of the clear when I had
more my normal parts spell desert light
you know kind of smells early yeah oh
yeah and that was like the ghost signal
and sure enough later that day back to
normal
wow what a neat story yeah yeah yeah and
how does it get ice it's all that
bacteria in your gut okay
all right I don't have to do the kid ate
not only killed your germs for your
what's wrong with you but they also
getting a gutting and oh I have to tell
you this okay having lots with the
doctor mm-hmm it was like 85 and in
don't know if you ever heard what's
called CDF but it's a bacterial
infection that is really a result of
taking too many antibiotics okay
very common in nursing homes and today
with people just take too many
antibiotics and get to see that's all
right well you know a lot of people they
say take probiotics and all the stuff
but deep what they really need to do is
introduce
shit back into your your good in the old
days these to give you shit enemas they
give you
somebody else's shit into your gut in
order to reintroduce ya bacteria what
about just doing 91 well you know I'm
sure that somebody might want to do that
for some but I would just acted by yeah
it is interesting so by the way did you
know that they used to do that or no no
I never knew that until here earlier
this year when I was have a lots of this
doctor Wow
she an animal what's the that's the
condition called seed if she gets yeah
wait smell it she yeah a plasterer e di
FF she gets okay
oh by the way speaking of shits how
about your bedspread is everything cool
with that now
oh yeah yeah that is cool yeah cuz you
shit on it I did I did but whether I get
mine we're good to go okay no it's yeah
and really I'll tell you how to it takes
a lot of room in the washing you only do
one play in the washer and then the
dryer and stuff you know it's a lot of
work to y'all so that's what I'm fine
yeah you're fine huh okay and the best
friends fine yeah what you do is if
you're by yourself I myself I did this
you know you just take that if the
shitty part you just going to fold it
the other way so it doesn't get on yeah
okay let me just sleep but but you
didn't do that right then you wash it
right away you know I think I did it the
next day to tell you the truth okay does
it so much trouble
you shouldn't stay in a shit-filled
bedspread yeah oh my gosh that's
barbaric man I know I know but you know
it's your own stuff so who cares okay
uh-huh
I do I think I would probably get up
it's really that's real savage my own my
own brand was involved in that much okay
um Jesus Ben so you just hung up I guess
how he did it I bet in his face yes I
bet you divorce he mashed it wash it'll
be the first thing you say I'm gonna buy
you my face in it cuz up